cette vidéo est faite en partenariat
avec france générosités plus
d'informations en fin de vidéo il ya
cinq ans je fais une retraite méditative
et pendant dix jours j'ai pratiqué le
noble silence ça qu'en gros on ne
parlait pas ou bien très peu en fait on
parlait mais seulement à nos professeurs
pour mieux comprendre la pratique de la
méditation et entre nous en fait on se
parlait pas elle non seulement se
parlait pas en ce regard d'eva non plus
voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils appelaient sa
noble le silence est une des règles du
ch il a donc ce qu'on devait appliquer
sur place et donc qu'ils sont des règles
liées au bouddhisme c'est de ne pas
mentir donc pour être sûr qu'on ne
demande pas eh ben on n'a pas droit de
parler bon c'était très simple et je me
suis avec eux du coup c'était hyper
important pour moi de ne pas mentir
c'est quelque chose que j'essaie
toujours de faire au maximum de mon
quotidien mais là après dix jours de
silence forcément j'étais hyper attentif
sur le moindre petit mensonge je suis
revenu à paris et en fait mon premier
mensonge c'était genre quelques jours a
pas de choix rentrée où j'ai croisé un
sdf qui me demandait si j'avais de
l'argent et j'ai dit j'ai rien et en
fait
c'était pas vrai quoi ça que je dois à
ma carte j'imagine ma carte bleue donc
j'aurais pu aller retirer et lui donner
donc c'est un peu un mensonge de dire
que j'ai rien j'ai et je pourrais faire
l'effort
mais j'ai pas envie bas dans cette vidéo
je vais me demander pourquoi je vais
demander pourquoi parfois on donne
parfois on donne pas et c'est quoi ce
lien qu'on a avec notre générosité
finalement par exemple sur pourquoi je
n'ai pas donné à ce moment là il ya une
première explication qu'on peut
peut-être trouvé chez arthur
schopenhauer dans le fondement de la
morale c'est l'importance de reconnaître
l'autre comme son égal sont semblables
pour agir en tant qu'homme bon aure
inconsciemment et indépendamment de
notre volonté on s'identifie pas de la
même manière à un mendiant qui a des
habits sales qui assis par terre qui va
très peu nous parler par rapport
un gars du taf un collègue qui vient
nous gratter 2 euros à la machine à café
quoi même si je prends pas de café vert
et que je n'ai pas de machine à café
d'ailleurs j'ai pas de collègues non
plus
je suis très seul je suis très très sale
dans le deuxième cas en fait on donnera
quasi systématiquement ce qu'on a dans
nos poches quoi et c'est hyper vicieux
parce qu'en fait plus la personne elle
est déshumanisé - on va vouloir l'aider
or plus elle en a besoin car c'était une
première explication
on peut retrouver d'autres par exemple
on sait là les plus sournoises elle fait
référence à l'utilité de notre action
par exemple si un ou une inconnu nous
demandent cinq balles pour payer un
trajet en train on sait clairement à
quoi va servir cet argent donc on a une
sorte de but à notre générosité c'est
très clair je venais de l'argent ça a
permis à cette personne de prendre son
train voilà je vois l'impact clair de
mon action et alain vers ce qu'on veut
donner par exemple à des mendiants ou à
certaines assauts
parfois une distance entre notre don et
ses répercussions et ça ça rend le
processus du don un peu moins fluide
quoi on va se poser des questions jean
va se dire ou es ce que va mon argent
est-ce qu'il va vraiment servir à quoi
il va servir est ce que j'ai réellement
un impact etc etc et c'est là
qu'intervient un autre phénomène qui est
intéressant et qu'on retrouve dans tous
nos choix c'est qu'on a peur de se faire
abuser on a peur d'être trop naïf on a
peur de se faire manipuler en fait de
manière générale on reconnaît une forme
d'intelligence aux fêtes se méfier et
donc il ya pas mal de choix qui serait
dû en fait non pas à un manque de
générosité mais plus à une peur enver de
de passer pour quelqu'un d' idiots
quelqu'un de bête quelqu'un de naïf sauf
que la générosité c'est peut-être
précisément ce à agir par principe sans
se demander ce que je vais récupérer en
contrepartie que ce soit positif ou
négatif tout ça c'est ce qui peut nous
pousser à ne pas donner mais ce qui peut
nous pousser à donner est tout aussi
intéressant mickaël mangot qui est
spécialiste d'économie comportementale
et d'économie du bonheur a fait une
étude sur les conséquences du don et
dégagent 4 bien fait déjà ça génère du
plaisir en fait ça stimule la même zone
du cerveau quand on reçoit du plaisir
suite à une récompense les émotions sont
plus positives que si on se ferait
quelque chose à soi même en psychologie
on appelle cette sensation le web glo 1
donc voilà la lueur chaude en gros on
aime plus sa vie en fait qu importe le
niveau d'investissement on se rend
compte que les gens qui donnent plus
sont plus satisfaits de leur vie de
manière générale et enfin il ya un
bien-être durable parce qu'en fait se
tenir à un principe
ça fait qu'on n'est plus en accord avec
soi même et qu'on a une meilleure estime
de soi donc en gros si je résume le don
c'est s'injecter à soi-même un cocktail
de choses hyper positive et en plus on
donne quelque chose à quelqu'un j'aime
le principe donc c'est a priori hyper
positif non je ne comprends pas pourquoi
tout le monde ne donne pas en fait et ça
c'est une bonne question pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui donnent beaucoup
qui donne mal acquis sont généreux et il
ya des gens qui sont égoïstes comment ça
se fait eh ben ça c'est exactement la
question que s'est posée le neuro
économiste ernst fehr professeur à
l'université de zurich et oui en fait la
neuroéconomie ça existe c'est l'étude de
l'influencé de facteurs cognitifs et
émotionnelle dans le comportement
économique des individus et pourrait
voir cette question va elle a fait une
étude il a fait cette étude en juillet
2012 il a pris les gens et il leur a
donné de la thune donc déjà le mec
extrêmement cool on envie de la voir en
tant que pote clairement et ces gens
devaient répartir cette une comme il le
voulait entre eux et une personne
anonyme et on qu'ensuite il a observé
les résultats et caetera et s'est rendu
compte que les gens étaient extrêmement
différents voilà il y avait il y avait
des gens qui donnait tout y avait des
gens qui donnait rien il y avait du 50
50 etc etc jusque-là ernst n'a rien
trouvé tout il n'a même pas trouvé une
deuxième voyelles dans son prénom et
beaucoup de conseils ernst non jeu ça ne
surprend que moi du coup il s'est pas
arrêté là il allait plus loin et s'est
intéressé à ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau des participants et là elle a
marqué deux choses d'abord il a remarqué
que les gens les plus généreux ils
avaient une plus grosse proportion de
matière grise à la jonction entre les
lobes pariétaux et en pot voilà c'est
une zone qui est situé genre derrière
l'oreille qui est impliqué dans
l'empathie et le fait de pouvoir se
projeter à la place de quelqu'un d'autre
mais surtout il a remarqué que cette
zone s activaient chez les égoïstes
quand le coût de l'acte généreux est
très faible j'ai les généreux quand le
coût de l'acte généreux et très élevé du
coup il en a conclu que cette zone est
savez à contrebalancer l'égoïsme
naturelle de l'homme en gros plus il
faudra compenser l'intérêt direct de
l'individu plus cette zone elle sera
sollicité chez les égoïstes leurs
intérêts il est plus important et donc
cette zone va s'activer hyper vite alors
chez les généreux bas y pensent - à
leurs intérêts donc ça met plus de temps
je voulais une question qui se pose
c'est est ce que on est généreux ou pas
est-ce que c'est un truc qui est qui
n'est en fait qui est prédéfini par
rapport à cette donne dans l'auto et
bien ernst fehr pense tout l'inversé ils
pensent que non il pense qu'en fait
cette zone on peut même au contraire la
développer et donc s'entraîner à être
généreux en fait selon lui la quantité
de matière grise dans le cerveau et
dépend notamment de facteurs sociaux et
donc peut l'augmenter cette quantité à
travers certaines normes sociales ou
même à travers un entraînement donc en
fait si vous êtes radin et que vous
voulez être un petit peu plus généreux
et bien en pratiquant ça peut le faire
faire
[Musique]
faire comme le ernst fehr en fait un jeu
de mots mais en fait ils marchent à
l'écrit à l'oral il marche pas du tout
tout ça peut le faire on ne peut pas
savoir que je le voyais faire fea cher
personne ne pouvait savoir ça donc il
fallait que je le dise quoi donc là on a
appris deux choses être généreux ça fait
du bien mais pas dans la même proportion
pour tout le monde ok mais alors du coup
ci est généreux ça fait du bien
on fait pas pour nous mêmes en fait
j'en reste que c'est pas juste pour
recevoir du bonheur qu'on est généreux
est ce que finalement la générosité se
serait pas une forme d'égoïsme et bien
ça c'est la vision de marcel mauss
marcel mauss et le daron de
l'anthropologie française et il a
beaucoup écrit sur le don en fait pour
lui quand on fait un don on passe un
contrat social avec la personne qui
suppose un contre don c'est à dire une
réciprocité ok ça que quand on fait un
don on attend quelque chose en retour et
ce contre don et le qualifie de libre
est obligatoire alors dit comme ça ça a
l'air incompatibles mais en fait ce qui
veut dire c'est que on est dans une
société basée sur les changes et donc
quand on fait un don on met en place
directement une relation de pouvoir et
de reconnaissance entre le donneur et le
receveur et cette relation elle incite
le receveur à rendre un équivalent mais
du coup par le simple dont le donneur
reçoit déjà une contrepartie puisqu'il
reçoit la reconnaissance donc pour les
plus généreux ce dont il est déjà
remboursé en fait automatiquement par
cette reconnaissance qui suffit en fait
et d'ailleurs cette reconnaissance elle
est plus importante que ce que vous
pouvez penser et peut-être que certains
se rappellent d'un épisode du coup de
fil sur la dialectique de hegel pour
eagle ce désir de reconnaissance c'est
le désir humain fondamental pour lui une
conscience ne peut sentir exister que si
elle est reconnue par une autre
conscience que soit donc pour se faire
reconnaître on est motivés par notre
désir de reconnaissance donc quand on
donne on reçoit cette reconnaissance et
enfin quand on dit ça on peut avoir
l'impression que voilà ce qui donne
c'est juste des égoïstes qui sont avides
de reconnaissance et qui donne pour soi
c'est une manière de voir les choses
mais on peut voir les choses autrement
aussi on l'a vu nos actes généreux ils
peuvent être motivées pour des raisons
biologiques anthropologique
philosophique mais ce que ça change
vraiment leur impact l'égoïsme c'est pas
forcément tout garder pour soi et rien
donner aux autres peut-être que parfois
c'est donner aux autres et trouver
quelque chose pour soi et dans ce cas là
ça change quand même pas mal la vision
qu'on peut avoir de l'égoïsme cette
vidéo elle en collaboration avec france
générosités dans le cadre de leur
campagne vos dons agissent qu' une
campagne non pas de dons mais de
sensibilisation au don c'est l'occasion
pour vous de faire parler l'aspect
généreux de votre égoïsme et d'ailleurs
je vous invite à aller sur le site info
dont point fr en fait vous allez trouver
plein d'associations différentes plein
de causes différentes et donc
comment et à qui donner et c'est
aujourd'hui avec tous les outils qu'on a
notre disposition c'est tellement simple
de faire un don ça se fait en un clic et
d'ailleurs en trois ans les dons en
ligne des français ont doublé donc la
flemme c +31 arguments et il ya beaucoup
de gens qui dépendent de ces dons ça on
s'en est rendu compte avec la crise
sanitaire où on a vu qu'en fait les dons
entre 2019 et 2020 ont augmenté de 13,7
pour cent ces dernières années beaucoup
de gens ont été confrontés à la misère
de près ou de loin et donc ça a provoqué
un élan de générosité et d'ailleurs les
français mais en fait on donne pas mal
56% des français donnent quel que soit
leur niveau de revenu et sur ses 56 % et
1 à 94 % qui sont des donateurs fidèles
donc régulier donc en fait il ya
beaucoup de gens à aider il y en a pour
toutes les sensibilités que soit le
mendiant qui habite en bas de chez vous
ou bien vous même dans 20 ans quand il
fera 50 degrés en été par exemple merci
à frans générosité c'est pas souvent
qu'on a l'occasion quand même de faire
une vidéo
sur sur ce sujet là et pour voilà pour
non pas inciter les gens à donner une
cause spécifique mais juste au principe
de données je vous sachant mais je
savais en trop cool donc voilà prenez
vos shot de sérotonine n'hésitez pas
allez sur le site un vos dons point fr
je vous remets vous avez vraiment plein
de causes différentes plein d'assaut
différentes etc ces chants mais
évidemment fait le hauteur de vos
capacités nous vous mettez pas dans le
rouge c'est pas le but je vous embrasse
très for love peace ciao